hello my name is what don't your Alain
well you mean be bugs and the question
this is going around is how would I make
a world a better place what number one
every human being should have access to
drinking water they should be able to
grow their own food and freedom of
movement we we take for granted that we
can go anywhere I'm an American citizen
I know I can go pretty much anywhere so
I think that if you have the opportunity
to travel and to see other people and to
experience how other human beings live
in other parts of the world I think that
can bring people together but me being
an artist I think everyone should be
able to put something out there through
art so my art is rebuffed and every
character has their own soundtrack so
maybe Bill Gates has song in his head so
he should get that song and bring it out
with the beatbox so if we can exist and
learn about each other through sound
because everyone has a sound they can
make so maybe we don't have to speak a
language will speak a language that's
just music because music is universal
and everyone understands that language
so that is my take to make a world a
better place